Today's video is sponsored by audible check the link in the description for a free audiobook when you start your 30-day trial
Hey guys. I'm Nate welcome back to the workshop
We've got a couple of chemicals that we've used at the past and today
We're going to combine them, and see how they work out
We've got liquid nitrogen, which we've done a lot of *cool* experiments with and here. We've got a tank of sulfur hexafluoride
In case you don't remember
[DEEP VOICE]: Sulf
Sulfur hexachloride has the opposite effect of helium on your voice if you breathe it in
pretty cool [BREATHES OUT]
[NORMAL VOICE]: Of course you want to make sure you don't keep the sulfur hexafluoride
In your lungs for too long because it's much heavier than air and will actually displace any air in your lungs
Which could make you lightheaded dizzy or even pass out
So today we're gonna see what happens if we fill a balloon with sulfur hexafluoride
And then put that into some liquid nitrogen cooling it down to over 300 degrees Fahrenheit below zero
Clearly a standard balloon when blown up will not fit into the mouth of this container
But I think we can squeeze it enough that it starts to fit in and I'm counting on the liquid nitrogen
Shrinking the volume of the gas think the whole thing will collapse down to the point where it can all fit inside this container
Let's give it a try!
[INFLATES BALLOON]
There we go whole balloon, a whole balloon full of sulfur hexafluoride
Now I am going to try and do this without tying a knot in it because I might want to open the balloon after depending
On what it looks like has happened inside my tap overestimated. How well I could deform this balloon to fit it in the container
Since I can't really fit the balloon in I'm just gonna try and scoop some liquid nitrogen out and pour it over the balloon
See what we get
The balloon is definitely shrinking, that's working well
There we go and
The neck of this is still very much twisted off. Nothing is escaping out of the balloon
It's just that the volume of the gas is getting much much smaller, and I believe it's turning solid
Let's take a quick break to learn about our sponsor audible.com
Audible is offering listeners a free audio book with a 30 day trial membership
They've got a huge selection of audiobooks comedy news and more personally
I'm a big fan of sci-fi and fantasy and recently I've been listening to opera by Brandon Sanderson
It's the 3rd book in a Stormlight archive
Series one of my favorite things about using audible is that it lets you keep track of your place in the book even if you
Switch from one device to another go to audible.com slash king of random and browse their unmatched selection download a free title and start listening
Now let's go back to our experiments
That is a balloon
full of solid
Sulfur hexafluoride a very very cold balloon full of solid sulfur hexafluoride
Let's let this warm back up and see if it's still full of sulfur hexafluoride gas way
We'd expect it to be there you go. That's a chunk of sulfur hexafluoride right there
Shaking around in the balloon the balloon itself is wearing back up, but the sulfur hexafluoride inside has not
Our balloon is still very cold
So it's getting frost on the outside. I'm trying to just keep wiping that off so we can see inside
And see the balloon is filling back up just gonna try and use the heat of my hand
To melt the sulfur hexafluoride I guess it's not gonna melt. It's gonna sublime
It's just making my hand really cold. Oh, yeah. It's definitely making my hand really cold
anywhere those little
Specks it for just a second really cools down the balloon a lot leaves marks on you can see maybe a little bit of vapor
Condensing on the bottom where it's sitting it's getting pretty close
I don't want to try breathing any of this gas in while they're still frozen
Particles in here because then it's possible
They could get blown out with the moving gas and have frozen particles of sulfur hexafluoride in my lungs
That sounds like a very bad experience to me. Oh I forget how heavy this stuff is this balloon is just like
Pulling down so hard. It feels like gravity is increased like you just as way more
Dropped to it than a normal balloon
Think we are
We gasps off' i'd all of our sulfur hexafluoride in this balloon that looks like about the size that it was before we started
So I think this is worked out pretty. Well. I'm gonna try breathing some of it in see if it still has the same effect
Look at you think I think it says like it still has the exact same effect even have to be frozen and fan and
That really settles in your lungs it's still a little bit of air
There's one more experiment
I want to see if we can do I want to take another balloon shrink it all down so all the sulfur hexafluoride is solid
And I want to cut it out and then based on what I just did here
I want to see if I can compress it down in sort of all one pellet and
Then take that pellet can fit it inside a new balloon
And tie that off and let it expand and see if I can successfully transfer sulfur hexafluoride in solid state from one balloon into another
Why I don't know it just seems like
It'd be neat
Heavy balloon
There you go
solid sulfur hexafluoride right there
very very cold stuff
And it's a lot like solid carbon dioxide
usually known as dry ice it doesn't pass through a liquid phase at peace temperatures and pressures it goes straight from a solid into a
Gas you can see what's coming off of there is probably sulfur hexafluoride
Turning into gas it also might have a little bit of condensed water vapor in with it all right
And I think that's most of our sulfur hexafluoride of course. We've lost a little bit of it as it warmed up
I'm now trying to compress it down and that seems to be working all right. I think I've got kind of a good
Pellet of sulfur hexafluoride here, I'm just gonna take the chance and lick it. Well. I can easily hold on to it
Doesn't really seem to do much kind of like licking an ice cube
No flavor whatsoever all right now. Let's see if I can manage to
force this chunk of sulfur hexafluoride
Down into this balloon without it just completely freezing
There we go
that is a chunk of sulfur hexafluoride in the balloon I
Squeezed the air out as much as I could
once the sulfur hexafluoride is in there so now we can just watch you can see it's already starting to expand a little bit and
Everything in there should just be sulfur hexafluoride
That's in there. I wonder if I can break that chunk back up
It's somewhat broken up
And I kind of shake it and keep my hands on it to add some warmth
Try and blow that back up as much as it's gonna go
Here we have a demonstration of how fast our liquid nitrogen is expanding inside of our thermos kind of a lot
Currently the neck of the balloon is covering the only
exit from this container of liquid nitrogen
And so we can see about how much liquid nitrogen
Is turning into a gas at any given time when you can see this balloon is growing at a decent rate
Alright our sulfur hexafluoride has now completely
sublimated back into a gas
We have our heavy balloon you may notice this balloon is definitely smaller than the one we originally filled with sulfur hexafluoride
for this particular experiment
And I'm sure that's just because we lost some of the sulfur hexafluoride as we were transferring it from one balloon to the other
Yeah go in there now let's cut the neck off. I'll breathe this in and see if it gives us the same effect
We're used to a sulfur hexafluoride
What do you think sounds to me like it's still looking just the same even after being transferred from one balloon into another
And then you gotta breathe it out, so you don't pass out that might be on here tight enough
And it doesn't want to pop itself off this might just not have enough pressure
So we might just have our balloon explode, and I want to just step back for help minutes and let that do its thing
It's getting kind of narrower down at the neck which might be
Pulling it differently
Whoa?
That was a ringer Wow
Well there you go a nice little mini experiment right now a balloon covering the nozzle of this tank it definitely
Warms up enough to put out some vapors of liquid, nitrogen
Enough pressure to burst a balloon and that only took maybe
10-15 minutes total to blow up that whole balloon and then pop it
Pretty fun stuff there we go now
We know what happens if we put sulfur hexafluoride into a balloon and freeze it in liquid, nitrogen
It doesn't actually go into a liquid phase at least in this pressure in the air
It goes straight from the gas into a solid then it warms back up it turns back into a gas
I thought it was especially fun
We were able to take some of the solid hexafluoride out of the balloon
Smoosh it down into sort of a pellet and fit it into another balloon
Where it then warmed back up and inflated that balloon? It's an interesting way to transfer sulfur hexafluoride
Probably not very practical for most means, but I thought it was cool that it works
Thanks for joining us for this video and remember to come yourself with barbecue look at the king of random dot-com see you there
The answer that sounded went if you play the video it ups the movie now completed double speed and sounds morning
And of course oh man
Again thank you to audible for sponsoring this video go to audible.com slash king of random or text king of random to five zero zero
five zero zero for a free audiobook when you sign up for a trial 30-day membership